[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la technologie est incroyable et nous
donne accès à une tonne d'informations
ou conjoint on peut tout savoir ce qui
se passe dans le monde
dès que ça se produit puis partager ça
avec méthode d'ailleurs on a des
milliers d'amis bien plus elle aime à
faire plusieurs choses en même temps ne
peut pas suivre sur cinq
mais cette technologie est ce que c'est
de nous de meilleurs humain
un samedi matin cet automne mon épouse
maudit en fin de semaine il faudrait
être sûr et par la souffleuse c'est le
moteur de la chute qui fonctionnait pas
très bien au site sûrement remarqué
qu'une des pierres sur notre tour de pvc
déplacés pourrais tu nous prépares est
sa [ __ ] en quête d'or pour être aussi
regarder la toiture
c'est le ces enquêtes avaient vu dans
l'entretoit moi j'ai jamais réparé de
souffleuses n'y avait ni toiture qui
voudrait que chasse tout ça en un week
end pour me prend pour un super héros
les super héros sont sympathiques lice
ferrero ils nous font rêver
il nous donne du courage il nous pousse
à nous dépasser
vous commencez avec une petite idée
toute simple dans l'espoir qu'un jour et
va changer le monde
vous risquez pour réussir pas plus que
moi mais pendant que vous essayez d'y
arriver
vous apprenez toutes sortes de nouvelles
choses et l' aventure elle est vraiment
fantastique
et aujourd'hui je suis entouré d'une
équipe de jeunes passionnés avec qui on
invente des nouveaux pouvoirs de
super-héros le domaine de recherche
principal c'est la réalité augmentée qui
vont bientôt si ici dans tous les
aspects de notre vie en facilitant
l'accès à l'information
tenez par exemple vous êtes intéressés à
connaître les heures d'ouverture de ce
magasin mais vous y pointer simplement
votre téléphone et l'application de
réalité augmentée va afficher des
informations directement accroché au
magasin pour notre équipe de recherche
développé des prototypes d'utilisation
de la réalité augmentée dans le monde de
l'ingénierie
par exemple un employé municipal
pourrait afficher des informations
relatives à des bâtiments simplement en
y pointant sa tablette ou constater
l'avancement des travaux de construction
d'un bâtiment
ou même grâce à des lunettes spéciales
de réalité augmentée visualiser des
tuyaux souterrains sous la surface du
sol grâce à la réalité augmentée
le monde entier va devenir une porte
d'accès à l'information
mais un autre type d'informations que
fait notre succès au cours de l'histoire
on est passé d'une espèce
essentiellement forestière à des êtres
qui vivent dans une société organisée
puis qui ont inventé les langues les
maisons la littérature la médecine
l'internet puis la démocratie toute
cette évolution s'y produire sur une
période un peu plus longue que la durée
vu dung so lu ment et le donc été rendu
possible grâce à la transmission des
connaissances ce que vous savez en tant
que technicien ingénieur professionnel
médical mais on transmet la prochaine
génération qui vont pouvoir à son tour
reprendre le travail
et participez à l'évolution de la
société
malheureusement au sein d'une entreprise
les employés les plus expérimentés sont
pas toujours disponibles pour enseigne
ou nouveaux alors voici une façon avec
laquelle on peut utiliser la réalité
augmentée pour faciliter ce transfert de
connaissances hockey tchèque cech
c'est une bonne manière de faire faire
le travail sans erreur mais suivre
bêtement des instructions comme si
c'était un gps ça nous incite pas
beaucoup à réfléchir pour comprendre
pour bien enseigner il faut aller plus
loin
tenez par exemple l été dernier mes
beaux parents ont décidé de vendre leur
maison une belle maison centenaire sur
la réussite du sénat comme il avait
habité à cet endroit depuis une
cinquantaine d'années vous pouvez
imaginer qu'ils avaient accumulé un
certain nombre d'objets dont il fallait
se débarrasser avant le déménagement
or j'étais cordialement invités
participer à cette humble d'âge pendant
que je vidais le sous sol j'ai réalisé
que des fenêtres est en mauvais état et
devait être remplacé
or dans le contexte la solution la plus
simple consistait à la remplacer par de
la brique mais moi je connais pas ça de
la brique en fait comme s'il est le
gendre qui avait si aimablement suggéré
cette solution au lieu de demander de
faire le travail mais moi je connais pas
sûr de la brique
j'en ai jamais posée donc chez lui sur
le web où j'ai trouvé des vidéos de gens
qui montrent comment monter des murs de
briques
puis j'ai regardé attentivement
j'ai pris des notes puis je suis
redescendu sous sol
j'ai tenté de faire la même chose
étonnamment j'ai réussi j'avais fait mon
premier mur de briques
j'étais fier grâce à internet
j'avais appris une technique que je
connaissais pas mais c'était pas parfait
j'aurais préféré avoir quelqu'un à côté
de moi qui m'aurait et montrer étape par
étape comme maintenir ma briques avec ma
main gauche
comment déposer ciment avec matt ruelle
j'aurais pu m'approcher
regardez d'un point de vue différent
poser des questions mende et répété une
étape on ne tentait de faire ça dans
notre laboratoire
nos programmes et on a enregistré un
expert en 3d pour le programme une autre
application de manière à ce qu'on puisse
interagir avec lui
firth perforé deux unités chèque de paie
cheval
du fun transcrire des skavens du rock
and that c'est vraiment intéressante
pour interagir ainsi avec un ordinateur
comme si c'était un humain mais dans cet
exemple
toutes les questions sont possibles il
faut que les réponses a été
préalablement enregistrées par l'expert
il nous faudrait quelque chose plus
interactif un logiciel auquel on
pourrait poser n'importe quelle question
sans qu'on ait besoin d'enregistrer
d'abord des réponses
une sorte d' humains virtuels
intelligents pour pouvoir développer un
tel humains virtuels
il faudrait pouvoir bénéficier de la
magie de l'intelligence artificielle
malheureusement la science a fait de
bons progrès dans le domaine mais intel
humain virtuel est pas encore tout à
fait possible aujourd'hui
mais pour un instant supposons que ce
soit possible
qu'est-ce que ça permettrait de faire
tenez par exemple un employé d'une usine
de rencontre un problème avec un
équipement les collègues qui peut
demander conseil on eut même une
expérience limitée
en fait la connaissance d'une entreprise
avait distribué dans la tête de tous ses
employés quelqu'un qui travaille dans
une autre usine par exemple en argentine
ont peut-être la solution à son problème
mais comment savoir
alors voici une manière qu'on ne simulé
dans notre laboratoire qui montre
comment les humains virtuels
intelligents pourraient être utilisés
pour faciliter le transfert de
connaissances au sein d'une entreprise
est close
le tango
halperin a et arrière
6 comment pour edward hart et tu vois il
faut rationner celui-là bâle-ville a
abaissé une intensité un gradé des
favoris est ramenée à 10 mbit/s liste
initiale des processus d'aggravation de
la star à la 6e' l'espèce les juin
virtuels intelligents pour devenir une
véritable plateforme pour le partage des
connaissances au sein d'une entreprise
mais nos travaux de recherche dans le
domaine nous ont rapidement fait
réaliser que cette technologie pourrait
facilement dépasser le mur de
l'entreprise prenez par exemple ce que
vos parents vous ont appris ou ce que
vos amis vous ont dit que vous auriez
pas demander à vos parents ou même ce
que vous avez découvert vous même
toute cette connaissance et les limites
et personne connaît tous les trucs alors
vous risquez doit faire les mêmes
erreurs qui ont déjà été commises des
milliers de fois simplement parce que
vous ignorez les meilleures pratiques du
malheureusement la vie aviez pas avec un
manuel d'instruction je rêve d'un jour
où chacun nouveau disposer d'un
assistant virtuel qui sera toujours là à
côté de nous et qui aura accès à toute
la connaissance universelle
ça devrait quand même avoir un ami qui
c'est tout mixant vante pas je réponds
peur de me sentir inférieur à lui parce
que rien que moi pourrait le voir et
l'entendre serait en rien que pour
m'aider alors tout d'abord mon compagnon
mon assistant ce sera un compagnon
programmé pour ma 6t m'accompagner
depuis rennes en un sens il serait
toujours là à côté de moi il connaîtrait
comme s'il avait tricoté mon assistant
ce serait aussi un professeur qui
connaîtrait qui ré accès à toute la
connaissance humaine
il pourrait donc m'a montré comment
réparer une souffleuse qu'on va faire
tourner une pâte à pizza puis comic con
est très ciblé il serait quand même
expliquer les choses que je comprenne
rapidement mon assistant ce pourrait
aussi être un conte qui aurait qui
connaîtrait toutes les erreurs qui ont
été commises par tout le monde
il pourrait donc me guider habilement
vers une solution tout en laissant faire
des erreurs que j'apprenne par exemple
il pourrait jouer le rôle de l'emploi ya
pour me permettre de pratiquer
virtuellement une entrevue d'emploi
il me donnerait des conseils lorsque je
me pratique pour faire une présentation
devant un public aurait aimé l'avoir
celui là il serait toujours là à côté de
moi à me pousser à me dépasser et à
jamais refaire les mêmes erreurs
mais le plus important c'est que mon
assistant pourrais aussi me pas me
permettre de partager mon propre savoir
tout ce que j'ai appris tout ce que j'ai
découvert puis les erreurs pour laquelle
j'ai payé cher toute cette connaissance
et pourrait bénéficier à tous
alors je pourrai l'enseigné à mon
assistant qui lui l'a traduirait l'anc
audrey et la télé vers serait une sorte
d'encyclopédie ouverte globale et
universelle de la connaissance humaine
ce serait comme avoir un accès direct et
participatif à l'intelligence collective
un manuel d'instructions de la vie dont
tout le monde pourrait bénéficier
malheureusement les humains virtuels
intelligents pour être mal utilisé
on pourrait en venir à trausse 6e et
plus jamais faire d'efforts à toujours
se faire donner les meilleures solutions
on pourrait cesser d'en chercher des
meilleurs les humains virtuels pourrait
tuer notre créativité
il pourrait être utilisé contre nous
pour nous influencer nous contrôler ou
même violine du privé en fait on
pourrait même en venir à préférer la
présence des humains virtuels de celle
des véritables humains qui sont parfois
si compliqué cette technologie et
comporte des risques mais il faut pas
que ça soit la peur qui nous empêchent
d'avancer parce que s'ils sont
développées et utilisées de la bonne
manière
mention aux possibilités telles que qui
vous avertit lorsque vos actions risque
de mal tourner quelqu'un qui vous aident
à pourvoir le point de vue de l'autre
quelqu'un qui vous aide à passer à
travers les épreuves quelqu'un qui vous
donne l'impression que vous êtes un
super-héros quelqu'un quelqu'un qui vous
aident à devenir 116 une meilleure
version de vous même ça pourrait tout
seuls les humains virtuels ils vont
aller beaucoup plus loin que nous aider
à réparer une voiture ou un trottoir de
pavie ils vont nous pousser à nous
dépasser et à progresser en tant
qu'humain puis comme société au cours de
l'histoire
les humains ont montré qu'en travaillant
ensemble ils pouvaient accomplir de
grandes choses
malheureusement on est encore limitée
par notre capacité à connaître les
solutions que les autres ont trouvé
quand on est des milliards d'individus
il ya des limites au partage de
connaissances la technologie nous a fait
faire un pas de géant dans cette
direction ces petits appareils
ils font vraiment les merveilles mais en
se rappelant pour nous les choses
importantes
comment est-ce qu'ils affectent mémoire
en captant sans cesse notre attention
jusqu'à quel point ce qui nous limite
dans nos interactions sociales en
personne qui ont justement c'est le
succès dans l'histoire
je rêve d'un jour où la technologie
encore plus loin et nous permettra via
le partage de nos connaissances à tous
d'apprendre toutes sortes de nouvelles
choses et de véritablement devenir de
meilleurs humain il reste encore de
nombreux défis à relever pour développer
des
véritable les humains virtuels
intelligents mais vous le savez de nos
jours la technologie évolue à une
vitesse foudroyante
au cours des 50 dernières années notre
société a vu passer plusieurs
générations les disciplines et les
autonomes les connectés et bien sûr ceux
qui sont nés avec une tablette dans les
mains bien qu'on le veuille ou non qu'on
soit prêt à souvenirs je crois que la
prochaine génération pourrait très bien
être celle des super héros
merci
[Applaudissements]